first wanted to start by saying you made
me laugh a ton last night so I say I say
thank you because comedies are really
hard to do and so thanks thank you yeah
yeah I'm not very great I mean right so
I am curious though because it is super
r-rated and you and you have kids in it
what was the toughest thing to do with
the kids was it the kissing scene or was
it the sex choice sex doll sex toys I
felt where we were starting the kids
were kind of like they were playing with
it they're asking us questions we would
say talk to your mom we would kind of
walk away get a drink alcohol obviously
did you know that's where I get that's
where it gets a little but what you know
we basically said like we talked to
everyone on set about being respectful
not sharing things with the kids so be
it's just a different it's a different
environment than a you know than a
typical movie yeah I am I'll be honest
when I was 12 I would not know what some
of those things know so hopefully when I
was 17 I was gonna say I learned it last
week you're slowly starting to feel yeah
but was there I'm curious because it's
very it's very adult was there any
pushback was there anything that ever
along the way the studio or parents or
somebody was like okay that's just too
far no not really I mean you know they
know what they're signing up for you
know they read this they'd read the
script before they signed up and you
know things evolved but it never it
never kind of went into a direction that
was so far off from what they signed up
for completely
oh no I'm always curious about the
editing process because that's the final
rewrite what did you guys learn in the
editing room that may be impacted the
finished film just everything became
tighter you know like their anal subsea
yeah with the pacing of it so just you
want you want to kind of get you want to
get things going so I think like the
beginning of the movie could have been
before they kind of leave the school
could have been ten minutes longer and
that didn't work and then there was a
chunk in the middle we cut out a set
piece and it just by removing that thing
that we worked really hard on all of a
sudden these two other things came
together and the pace in the beat in the
middle of the movie where we're kind of
losing
laughs went away so you know a lot of
that and then also music music helps so
much and really changes the energy of a
scene do you envision a like are you
more of like do you like the idea of an
extended cut or these are just deleted
scenes for down the road I don't know I
mean I I like that you have an extended
cut for Apocalypse Now you know I don't
know if we need one for good boys I feel
like that mean the cup the cup that we
have I mean we this is the cup that we
believe in you know what I mean like it
wasn't the studio it's not like the
studio took it away from us or the
producers or anything like that like
collectively we watched it with
audiences and we all felt like oh this
is what we want to put out yeah um yeah
we're gonna say how many cuz test
screenings are now a huge but especially
for comedies yeah to know what works
what was it like that because you've
seen the material like a thousand times
so you probably walk into these test
screenings and you're like is this even
funny anymore like or do you sort of you
know what I mean what is it like um we
become slaves to the laughs so it
doesn't matter if we think it's funny or
not funny if it's working you can't deny
a camera moves Billy Wilder who said it
a single audience member can be an idiot
but together an audience is a genius and
you can't argue with if the whole
theatre sorry what happened we're not
laughing yeah do you believe in a joke
and they're not laughing it's not funny